when you got locked up was it during the
pandemic or before it was during the
pandemic well I caught the case like
2019 so I was out on Bill and then I
went down during the pandemic so I I
caught like the first little half you
got the first part of it I caught the
worst part of it yeah when it was like
you couldn't leave the house especially
in the bank shut down and there wasn't
no nothing in there so you get out and
San Francisco and like just the Bay Area
in general Oakland Everything Has
Changed drastically almost like it feels
like the pandemic kind of like might
have permanently damaged like the city
low-key like or the area like it
definitely did that [ __ ] looked like
it ain't the same from when I left for
sure 100 like um you know some of the
it's crazy the craziest [ __ ] is like I
think in the city of San Francisco you
could still
and shoplift up to a thousand dollars
and they can't arrest you have you heard
about this hi what
what the hell so like if if it's been
going viral like people will just go
into like now if you like if you're in
the city you'll see like the CVS's and
the Walgreens and [ __ ] too yeah because
everybody was just going in and just
stealing like 900 worth of [ __ ] and just
leaving and there's nothing they could
do about it yeah I think it was after
like a certain amount it's like
that's when it becomes big like it's
it's petty theft before then yeah like
they can't take you to jail they
probably write you a ticket or something
but they can't take you to jail they
can't arrest you [ __ ] that's crazy
that's how people using that like why
would I go pay for some [ __ ] exactly if
y'all if I'm not gonna go to jail yeah I
was just with uh you know what I'm gonna
shout my guy John Costa now shout out to
John costume me and John were in the bay
last weekend he shoplifted I said bro
what are you doing he stole the gum I
said I said John you can't add to the
problem what is wrong with you bro
just walked out to go it's just like
damn it's like it's not gonna happen
yeah you're right um but not definitely
um
it's crazy out there man it's just like
with the drug [ __ ] like you know this is
his dad obviously I feel like bipping
has gotten worse than it's ever been the
day I got to Oakland from jail this time
I stopped at cookies
I was in there five minutes the day you
got home oh man the day I got here the
day I got home
cookies to get some weed go in there
come back out the big whips I mean the
whip bits I said the whipped a bit but
yeah I said God I don't be a bit before
that's like my third time but I was like
bro this is how I get my welcome home
that just woke me up like
was there anything in the car they
didn't even take nothing it was [ __ ] in
there but they didn't take nothing it
was like they bent my window and got up
out of there or something like yeah I
feel like a lot of people tell me now
they're like yo if you come to the Bay
you have a rental car take everything
out just keep your windows rolled down
man because they're gonna bust your
window even if they don't see none they
just gonna crack the window off really
rolling your windows now just let people
go in and see what your car unlocked
everything just go ahead come on in for
the window yeah cause the wind getting
the window replaced the biggest headache
yeah that's it that's it crazy it's
insane man